Cindy is in Tucson hi Cindy how are you
good are you better than I deserve
what's up so well I'm really excited to
talk to you first of all and I just want
to let you know that you're getting a
lot of exercise biking and walking
around here because you go with me every
day well I'm feeling better already
thanks how can I help today
well so I've got this little moral
dilemma I gave my niece FPU when she got
married about six years ago and to my
knowledge she never went to it since
then she's gone to school she's she has
stood alone so you bought a brand-new
house recently and now she's having a
medical emergency and she wants to treat
it holistically and so she started a
GoFundMe account and she sent it to the
whole family
course she did my bilam is I'm just
having a hard time deciding if I should
donate to it or not it's not a dilemma
for me I'm not giving her a dime okay I
don't give money to people who do not
take my financial advice okay because
then I'm participating in their crazy
her financial plan is nuts because she
doesn't have one it's impulsive that's
irresponsible she buys whatever she
wants and then when there's a problem
she's a victim if you finance that you
are financing crazy yeah well I felt
like she's treating us like her
emergency fund that she doesn't have and
we we've worked really hard to get to
where I feel like you know that's why
she's asking us because she thinks we
have money but because we do have money
and and it's not hers yeah listen I'm
not being mean here the bottom line is
is that you guys you have done
absolutely nothing wrong you I would
have no tinge of guilt what
so ever this is like you walking up
somebody on the street and the guys
drunker than a skunk and he goes honey
money for food and you know what he
needs money for he needs money for a
drink and you're about to give a drunk a
drink that's that's what this GoFundMe
account is it's buying alcohol for an
alcoholic only difference is is a
different kind of misbehavior and you
it's not a loving act
it's a codependent toxic act for you to
respond to this lookup codependent read
the book boundaries by dr. Henry clout I
wouldn't give her a dime and I'd be kind
about it I just probably wouldn't
respond at all I just ignore it this is
the Dave Ramsey show